okay we're going to continue who I'm
thank you
the only time let's use kiyomi's weapon
against Kiyomi also known as already
ready was not on my list Alexa what's
the value of pi' okay thankfully it
ended before forever what do I play
let's play before it's kind of like
polish ready we'll see if he roaming is
ready ooh
also adoption right hey good morning
channel wait Channel I saw you earlier
today during the boat as match maybe
yesterday for you but still today for me
Oh
Kiyomi doing that my challenge be so
funny if kiyomi's doing with my
challenge unintentionally let's give
away a pawn I'm gonna induce Kiyomi so
taking my phones so that night the night
challenge will continue that would be an
interesting challenge though to induce
my opponent to move nights for the first
10 moves maybe it's possible this will
see I'm calculating this this goes back
and then g4 and then this and then each
three and then this ambition t2 and then
this way no well then b6 would be played
hmm I'll play we need to make any sense
let's play Queenie to slice act
I stocked a pawn for an open file Oh d5
good move
ah Kiyomi not doing the knight challenge
okay I'll play Bishop
it's getting interesting so I have the
bishop diagonal and the file 94 okay
Bishop d4 I mean the Knights are asking
you to get four just plant the bishop
I'm going for d3 it's a slightly
questionable but it's interesting
it's hard to force nights to move okay I
think we've had enough of this Alexa
stop singing me a song not sure what
song that was I hope that's not a soft
my like usual preferences okay D 3 D 3
the mic for key a lot of things kind of
lined up Wow all the pawns are really
enjoying attacking the Knights okay
weird things about to happen let's take
your first and then I'll take here I'll
take here with check and then take here
Wow
and then it's like double pawns with two
neighboring adjacent pawns how King King
g7
what does qo mean doing okay let's start
with a check this was played with good
intention but the king is going for a
run I don't know if we need Alexa to
drop a beat oh but the King just wants
to be hugged by my pawns that's so sweet
Eleanor Roosevelt said the purpose of
life is to live it to taste experience
to the utmost
here for newer and Richard you know
seventies is factorial if you say if you
say Alex and not Alexa it won't
understand what 776 factorial is also I
don't think too many people would okay
let's play oh is might be free here
might be free has been summoned okay
oh there's so many nice meeting ideas
the King being hugged being dragged
further into my a claiming territory
what is this position
mouki v6 King v6 interesting
I can push another pawn push another
point no Alexa don't don't
nope Alexa okay good um let's play I
sack a queen I could sack a queen hmm
probably dubious tohsaka Queen also this
is three plus two
time is running low okay
I'm dreaming of meet somehow some pawn
mates ooh
so I could play this and then this or
vice versa
wait a minute
can I psycho queen soccer Queen and then
that
no probably dubious okay let's play
let's play this only legal move and then
this will be makes oh that's such a nice
mates like King is sandwiched between
pawns of different colors it's like a
like an Oreo but the cream is on only
one side and then chocolate and then
okay well I put that on YouTube
Kiyomi I'm sorry for such brutal finish
without too much fun the Oreo cream meat
yeah wholesome Thank You G cook yeah
maybe I'll put that on YouTube because I
was this doesn't happen every day I was
thinking there was quadruple pong
potential if I get pons to keep capture
stuff on the C file but this was still
nice okay people on YouTube watching in
the future do I miss me then one people
on YouTube tell me in the comments if I
miss main one